originally i was running a plumbing and
heating business and i started i
installed my first groundswell seat pump
in 2003 and did solar thermal with that
and on the back of that i thought oh
this is all this is all got legs this
all works and we did our first pv system
in 2007 and on the back of that e-screen
energy was created as a renewable energy
only business i dropped my corgi gas um
regs and i dropped the oil off tech regs
or corgi at the time it's now gas safe
obviously
and just went straight for only
renewables we did heat pumps biomass
boilers and solar pv
we still do those three technologies
primarily
and
back in 2015 i bought out an electrical
contracting business as well because i
could see that the world was going
electric whether it's electric cars
electric heating it's all it's all
driven heat pumps it's all driven by
electricity
um so that was uh sort of a strategic
business decision that we made
and now we're pushing more more
still we still do residential work but
we're now pushing much more towards
commercial
systems and we're doing more commercial
pv than anything else but we do do
commercial biomass boilers it was my
question early on into the lady about
the district heating systems they now
want if we're going to do a district
heating system if we want any grant
funding it's going to be to 100 houses
and we just have that conversation about
developers and what they will or won't
tolerate
but it's uh it's mostly we're focusing
on commercial pv
i click that there i need to turn around
and make sure it's changed yeah
so
it's predominantly businesses are now
looking at reducing their carbon
footprint and the reason for that is
obviously because of climate change
and they're being driven by government
to to do this
um
that's when you we talked to the
environmental officer as the first
person that calls and says we want solar
pv and we go yeah that's absolutely fine
we'll get on and we'll get on and put a
quote together then the finance director
gets involved and the brakes all get put
on they go what's in it for us
i get the carbon savings but it's coming
out of our budget how we're going to
fund it so we then have to talk to them
about
the savings of the electricity bill and
also you now get paid much more
generously than you get for your export
you probably get paid three three and a
half p for your export
the the utility company's now paying 9p
um for export you you're contracted for
your 25 years so you can't you can't
leave your
you do get your 50 feet yeah but
yeah
so if you're replacing if you're
replacing an electricity um
if you're replacing bought electricity
from stuff that you're generating
yourself you're saving 15 to 20 pence
now
um and it but if you're if you send it
out to the grid the grid will pay you 9p
for it so even on that basis
it's traded it's brokered now and the
you could
um
get a contract for night for 9p going
forward for the next 12 months
if you go back a couple of weeks it was
being traded 28 pence a kilowatt because
this is how short we are of elect you
know they wanted to turn the gas grid
off and they wanted to buy electricity
so they want you to turn your
consumption off and sell the electricity
back to them so it's traded in real life
time and this is how batteries are all
um funded in term taking electricity off
the grid at slack times and putting it
back on at peak times so it it's it's uh
it's an interesting quite an exciting
area of renewables that isn't really
talked about but that's that's where
we're at i'm currently in in life time
and we do
mostly that changed good
[Laughter]
so far so good so we do um
four types of pv there's only three out
there obviously you all know about roof
mounted you know about ground mounted pv
systems
we do floating solar as a speciality
within east green energy and that is one
of the um
one of our growth areas but also it's a
specialism nobody else in east anglia
does it there's only two or three others
in the uk that do it
so typically we use
farmers reservoirs
their irrigation pumps run on
electricity
they've got a 90 kilowatt
irrigation pump we stick 90 kilos of pv
on on floating pontoons out out into the
middle of the reservoir it takes up no
more land
planning consent is done under permitted
development we've got most of them all
of that we've done so far we've got
through has permitted development
because it sits on the reservoir with a
great big bunded wall outside and that
you can't see it from
from anywhere unless you're flying a
drone over and we also do thin film
solar which is where the panels are
stuck onto typically a zinc
roof where they have the raised seam
part of a planning consent usually
and
the thin film is stuck directly onto
that
so that's
another
string to our bow
so i don't know if you've been to the
knot cuts garden center in norwich but
that's one of our pv systems
150 kilowatts of pv
saves 40 tons of carbon a year to them
knocks about 20 000 pounds a year off
their electricity bill
so that's
the driver we're saving the
they can say their environmental
credentials by the rejection of the um
of carbon and the finance directors
please because we're knocking so much
money after electricity bill
to interrupt you can we ask that
when i say i'm planning one's been at
things that to do the pool one business
park at great bacon yeah they got shed
loads of great big
sheds
and if you think of the gateway 14 plans
that mid-suffolk has
i think the best we've ever got as an
offer is the roofs are pv
ready
right right means you can imagine they
might get panels fitted on them sometime
in the future
so why don't people do it i mean the
story i've heard is that
the tenants get the
the uh the benefit and the uh
the person who holds the lease pays pays
down the panel was fitted so it doesn't
happen
so depending on depending on how long a
lease you've got
and
certainly
the landlords that we're dealing with
are recharging their electricity back to
the tenant
so
you're you're getting um
i think the carbon saving whether the
tenant is getting the carbon saving or
the landlord's getting carbon saving
that is uh out for discussion but
certainly the uh the tenant is recharged
for the electricity
and that so the landlord the landlord
pays them for the panels on the roof if
that's
and the tenant will pay for electricity
if the tenant pays them on the roof then
the tenant would get the electricity
so either or so
if it's a large consumer of electricity
then the payback is much shorter
if it's all being exported so you're
you're replacing a 20 pence kilowatt
payback shorter if you're exporting
electricity and being paid nine per
kilowatt for it the payback is twice as
long obviously um
uh just go back to the slides it's all
right now interrupt me interrupt
whenever you do but if they want us to
speak into the microphone then let's do
as we're told um
this job is in uh is in london near the
excel
exhibition center you can just see the
cable car going across the top there so
um this was a very prestigious job for
us it was great fun to do
plenty of headaches um it's very high
it's six containers stacked on top of
each other it's a containerized building
modular building using old containers
repurposed for this
the pv panels you can see in the middle
are ballasted on using concrete blocks
and around the edge there's a facade all
the way around the outside and we've
used the pv to shade the windows
underneath so that offers cooling to the
building um as well
i've got it over there look
i don't wiccan vineyard that's probably
that's in one of your first one in one
of your parishes stroke burrows yes
um so
it's a it's a large electricity use of
both on the farm with the irrigation
system and the um and the vineyard and
the um
the restaurant itself as well there's
150 kilowatts of pv we put there 150
kilowatts of irrigation pump that was
the main
reason that they had the pv was to
offset their irrigation costs and it's a
great synergy between
summertime use of irrigation pump
summertime generation of pv
so again i think we're talking
all the time
i've never noticed
all the times i've been to
uh wickham vineyard i've never seen it
so have we so it must be really well
hidden
yes and again it was because it's a
ground mounted pv system it's a full
planning application um
the house there is listed the uh so
very careful consideration of um
where you're siting them it's actually
sited beside the bund of the irrigation
reservoir there yeah but it is it's very
well hidden and again there was a full
environmental um
study had to be done uh as to when we
installed the pv system um time of year
uh and
and everything else making sure that we
weren't upsetting any ecological habitat
it was all taken care of within the
planning consent
yeah so wiccan
again 40 tons of
co2 saved
just running running off their pv
running off the pv system
the next one is our floating solar at
ravenium
so you can see the water there um
pv panels just
oh yeah
it's
[Laughter]
can i ask do the birds think it's water
and go crash bang wall up on it
no but they do we get a lot of bird poo
on it
that's how is it
so no we don't get them crash landing on
it we do get bird muck on the panels um
and we've developed a spray system that
runs off electricity off the pv panels
runs the spray system so we we run
little sprayers over them to keep the
birds from
from pooing on them yeah they tend to
land on the water beside it and then use
it as a roost
yeah yes
but weak but
[Laughter]
but we've uh we've found a way of
overcoming that um this is 90 kilowatts
of pv
90 kilowatts of irrigation pump um 25
tonnes of carbon
it's
all a bit of a no-brainer
and then again the design considerations
of a pv system i'm going to come back to
you your house presumably faces
relatively south ish
ridge face ridge runs yeah ridge runs
east west yeah
it's the same with with us and our
commercial buildings we want a southerly
aspect if we can
they tend to be flatter commercial
buildings maybe on your 10 to 15 degree
pitch which it all works perfectly but
you'll when you talk to people about
solar they'll say yeah i want to be 30
35 degree pitch well you you get what
you get with a roof that's already in
place
if we do it on the ground then we can
pitch them perfectly at 35 degrees and
pitch them south because we've got
the ground to play with
ground arrays are subject to planning
permission always
roof mounted systems permitted
development so long as we leave a meter
of uh of
clear edge around the outside of the
panels which you saw in the in the
norwich
garden center slide there's a nice gap
all the way around
so that's why it falls
because your plan is officers tell us
that's what that's this again part of
national planning policy
do we have we can
we have to leave a perimeter all the way
around that isn't covered in pv we if we
want to if we want to cover it then we
have to ask we have to get planned
permission
yep
uh and what we touched on very uh right
at the start of our conversation your
panels are 200 watts did you say
yeah yeah so the physical size of them
hasn't increased but their output has
doubled
and your your pv system got five six
years old
ten years old ten years old now yeah so
in ten years
output's doubled
so we're doing something
it's perfectly reliable
yes
touch wood
keep you guys away
touch wood yeah yeah
stop broken
[Music]
before you move on can i ask you where
they're manufactured
the panels
the vast majority of them are from
china korea um and japan there are
panels made in the in in europe
um
they i would suggest that they're
assembled in europe i think everything
is assembled i think we're in a global
economy some some
bits of kit come from america and some
from the far east and they're assembled
where they're assembled
even our american um panel manufacturer
we discovered this week that only one of
their models is actually manufactured in
america the others are done under joint
venture with companies in china although
they're sold as american panels so um is
there a reason for you asking
i don't particularly want to buy chinese
yeah yeah now we we can offer we can
certainly offer you a european
assembly
assemble panels
it would be the same as if you bought a
car made in the uk now
yes but but not not uh not that not that
big a difference though
yeah exactly yeah yeah
and
um
yeah
well we did for for a brief for a brief
time we had a system we had a
manufacturer in wales in sanyo made
panels in wales in in the uk again a
microwave factory apparently that they
converted into solar panel manufacture
but this is early days i haven't uh i
haven't heard of another uk manufacturer
that started since then
um
you would have thought so you would have
thought so yeah
yeah yeah you'd have thought soon
back to my presentation your second
business couldn't it manufacturing yeah
supplying yourself do you know how much
it costs to build away for fab uh
do i want to know is all a bit
rhetorical
[Laughter]
2
[Laughter]
you will have a string inverter
yeah where you group 16 to 20 panels
together into into a string and then you
feed multiple strings into an inverter
we still do the vast majority of of our
systems
actually splits near a 50 50 now but we
used to only do string inverters and now
commercial systems we fit
an individual optimizer or inverter runs
two panels
the reason for doing that is if you
cluster 16 panels together the worst
performing panel brings all the other 15
panels down to the performance of the of
the 16th panel
so if it's got some shade on it
it brings all the others down if it's
got some birdback on it it'll bring the
others down they all degrade slightly
over time if one degrades faster than
the other it brings all of them down to
that same output but if you have them
just paired or individually they're
treated as an individual item then the
whole system works more efficiently